ah hello everybody welcome um we are
playing bio mutant today
i played this game for the first time in
about four years ago i'll say i played a
really early build and i was super into
it from the moment that i first played
it
um so very excited to be playing it
today i'm just gonna play the first
hour and usually i would uh after doing
that here on youtube would jump over to
twitch because i am a twitch partner
i just can't stream on both platforms at
once but today um i had an asthma attack
this morning which means i have work
that i need to catch up on after doing
this so
we're just gonna do the first hour here
that seems barely visible to me
and i might need to make myself smaller
it's already very pretty alright yeah
gamers from thq nordic
of course are not technically actually
thq they bought the name and a bunch of
um licenses that thq did have like
darksiders
and i'm playing on the xbox series s
[Music]
and it looks very pretty
oh no
[Music]
um
naturally gameplay is not going to look
like this but this looks beautiful
uh k3 subway it's not cold as balls for
me i'm in a hotel room and it is very
warm
it basically feels like summer in here
i'm sure when i leave it'll be cold
uh tell me if i need to change any of
the um the settings
by any chance
um okay english
i'm kind of happy that i don't remember
a lot of what the initial gameplay was
like but i have seen people online
saying it starts with just a lot of
talking
or exposition how can something as
beautiful as this
a plague is ruining the land but the
tree of life still
stands question is for how long
end is coming to the new world the
tribes stand divided
in need of someone strong enough to
unite them
or bring them all down this
is a story with an unusual beginning i
like the vibe
let's expect right now i feel like it
looks like that uh the obsidian game
um the survival game where you're the
tiny human underneath the
with the spiders i feel what it's called
but the aesthetic is reminding me of
that
that's me welcome to biomutant
thank you sir let's do it
it's a lot prettier than i expected i
don't know why i'm thinking that though
obviously again
this isn't necessarily what the gameplay
is gonna look like
encode your dna okay i'm gonna move my
camera every time
it's always a little figure out what
this game looks like and then
find somewhere to put myself i miss my
green screen
hotel room setup just doesn't hit quite
the same probably have to move that when
gameplay starts um
okay choose your breed primal is nimble
developed anthromorphic breed a hybrid
with a gene mutation making them nimble
and dexterous
that is a bad way to explain that to
players i'm going to be honest
you could make this so much simpler um
[Music]
that compensates so that's just okay
let's just look at the stats
what do i want i like a healthy
character and i think i'm gonna like
intellect
so probably that one
he's cute
okay i think i'm gonna do this one
because it seems like the closest to a
mage
i don't know okay define your genetic
structure
oh i could do that anyway well it's very
hard to say when i don't know what
um i'm going to do i don't know what
what i need yet
uh i do have an xbox series x spirit um
and naturally i have a gaming pc
but because i am in australia i brought
an xbox series s because it's the
smallest console
and i'm streaming through the series s
for every game that i can through the
laptop basically to have two separate
setups just to
reduce the load on the laptop even
though it probably could run the game
just fine
um yeah i don't know what i should do
here
i like it intellect
but then i don't want to take away from
vitality there so maybe i just go bang
in the middle
i don't know man choose a genetic
resilience
genetic resilience [ __ ] okay
um i
which one is gonna help me the most
though you know
i'm going equal with a little bit more
for gold choose your first style
oh okay this is this is where we're at
this is what i would like to do
a strange way to do a customization
thing for this that one's cute pick your
main color
purple about here
choose your detail color
the detail color should have been the
purple if i'm being completely honest
we're going to make it just
white pick a class
commando sci freak
yes
okay did i do it all right i don't know
what any of it means
but let's find out thank you
appreciate that yes here's somebody with
a troubled past
drawn into the spotlight of us it feels
pretty good so far
what do you mean i can't beat up that
trash bag choosing a path in life is
that fork in the road where you make a
choice
or simply stop living oh wow
okay we're getting heavy out here um
all right i don't i go this way but for
you
it's not only a crossroad but a choice
a reflection of your key the primal
energy that flows through everything
seems a little bit dramatic if you ask
me
let's go light blue for freedom and
loyalty
let me introduce myself i'm the light
and bright side of you or your inner
voice to be precise
an echo of balance and consequence of
your actions as you move forward
sure seems more like you're being
light-headed if you ask me but you'll
come around
he seems like he'd be cooler to hang out
with i'm being honest like if i have to
pick between which one of these i have
to hang out with i would take the evil
one
but what comes around goes oh
in your nature and here i will do i get
both maybe
natural selection is all
[Laughter]
brilliant
right is always right
i feel like combat should be pretty good
but uh what is this is this
something i could no okay it feels like
it's going to control well
i see a lot of you saying that the
reviews aren't great death from the body
is left
behind i have a reminder that we're
reading a mercy of nature
on the one that preys on others
so i'm i'm kind of glad to not have read
them uh it means i get to go in
fresh see what i think do you remember
the beast that shattered so far it feels
like i'm playing metal gear
uh go to the patriots turned your back
for five seconds stop
walk for five seconds fast gotta have
cut scenes everywhere
the predator only grew stronger
okay i don't have a weapon but uh okay
i expected to be doing more made [ __ ]
but oh oh i see that's more of a like a
ah like a a uh
what's it to a bullet time type
situation all right
okay hit me fam let's do it
too late
all right that's pretty simple doesn't
look as satisfying as you'd want it to
generally
dx
i feel like a little bit of a jedi
very cool
you better make a run for it this is not
the time
no place to end this story okay
combat feels pretty floaty i could see
it
getting cool
not sure is my hot take so far
i don't know this time it was best to
run and live to fight another day
let us hope you're ready for it when it
comes
okay so i feel like this is
sort of what i remember playing
uh when i played the game at pax many
years ago
alright i don't know that i loved that
sound effect um okay well this is
this seems like combat arena the only
threat the wildlife
started to mutate when the end of days
began
and the tree of life started to die cool
love that for me move towards an enemy
to target them with melee attacks
aim the camera towards okay i have
played a video game but i respect that
maybe this is somebody's first video
game
okay oh cool
key energy is used for dodging mutations
okay it's basically just mana
ah there we go yeah i like that it's
like fable
or uh kingdoms of amalo or whatever
what did they say um what was it was lt
was something
you know obviously the gun that's it
okay
the um sound effect for that is seems
like an odd choice to me i'll say that
okay what's this dude what does this
mean oh i
was wondering if there was some kind of
finisher i maybe missed there
do you have a finisher is it just
telling me that you're dead
i'm sure you dented that one good
thank you sir i appreciate that okay
cool
[Music]
okay
hmm things i love things
my favorite i love weapon add-ons i do
you found a weapon special effect add-on
attach it to your range weapon to give
it an extra damage type that lasts as
long as the ammo lasts oh interesting
okay
uh to attach it
i think i already did that
because i hit equip i'm pretty sure that
is done
um i don't mind if people in the chat
don't like the game
if that's what people are saying i'm
fine with that they're allowed to not
like it
uh yeah i have no problem with people in
chat saying they don't like things
that's cool with me
cool wait but didn't i choose abilities
that would help me
older regen
um okay
what is this like fallout-esque bunker
situation that we've got going on here
oh see you can even check out toilets
there's a great episode of play watch
listen the podcast i do on this very
channel
with video game voice actor troy baker
video game director mike bethel and
video game composer austin wintery
myself being a writer to round that out
and um we did do an episode about how
you can really tell a lot about a game's
design in general from what the toilets
do
it's generally pretty true to most it
only means
who's this little guy some will have
adapted to the new
hello my friends change with it
evolution has its way
cute little guys remember to parry
correct thank you oh when i see
lightning bolts flashing
everybody's just very cute you know
i also don't imagine i can parry
oh no no no that's the wrong button i
forgot how to shoot
because i ran out of key we're gonna do
lt lt
no
your key is gone yes i see that that's a
huge bummer for me
hang on hang on i'm forgetting how to
shoot no there it is
it feels very weird to pull a gun out in
this game honestly
it feels like a mismatch
um okay
cool wonderful
this is gonna be something for me to
take sweet
we will take that also
i'm not sure if it's that i just was not
remembering how to do it or if because i
was pressing right trigger if it just
wasn't working the way that i expected
it to
i'm unsure um so far i feel like yeah
the combat is not super satisfying but i
also don't feel like i'm playing it
super well so
too early to say um i do like the design
i like the feel of it you know
am i still out of key oh i should have
dodged that one
just not sure about that mate can we
dodge this
did he blow his mate up i think he did
out of the way ah i ran right into it
okay
i just pull my shotgun out hang on
reloading don't mind me oh can i shoot
that
very nice oh that camera that'll get you
oh just i like that i can uh reload even
while evading
i shoot it in his hands damn close
this is going to be the thing that i
like the most i think is the
um the key with the lt and hopefully
they give us a proper wheel because
again like i said that's like fable one
kingdoms of amyloid mana systems
which i always really enjoyed um i was
so disappointed when
when fable 2 changed from that system do
i need to health regen i don't really
feel like i do
i feel like i'm doing okay out here also
are there collectibles
sludge will kill me now so far it seems
like the environments are
pretty basic not necessarily a lot to do
but that's okay
i agree and seven russ i do like the
aesthetic
um i have seen a couple of people say
that the the
sfx is strange and i would agree with
that i think
that's the sound it makes for melee
right
which is the sound that i keep saying
sounds very jedi
but there's not necessarily an impact
sound
um so there is sound which is probably
not what you
necessarily expect
and i can imagine that sound getting a
little annoying over time but like i
think that effect is really pretty look
like when we have the camera there
it does look really nice
and yeah i'm interested in the world for
sure and what all this
you know how how uh varied we might be
able to get with the mutations like how
different my loadout could be to someone
else's
i'm definitely interested in that oh
okay big guy some enemies carry large
shields you need to break the shield
with melee attacks before you can do
anything enemy okay
note it hello
let me break your shield real quick mate
not even hitting the shield oh okay
that was easier than i expected
there so he he wasn't blockable i
suspect
yeah what happened where are you going
boy
oh nice you're gonna keep running away
are we sure about that am i not supposed
to kill you what's happened here come
back
i will kick you in the shade did he get
health back rude
also he's dressed like a like an
absolute teenager this man
oh my god
y'all are doing damage to me out of
nowhere
what is this that you have some kind of
shotgun
oh oh my defeating enemies and
completing quests will give you xp
leveling up allows you to raise one of
your attributes by ten
you'll also get one point that you can
use to unlock skills in the wong
fu and parks menu okay
uh it's gonna be this one i imagine
increasing attributes when you level up
you can increase an attribute of your
choice by 10 pick which attribute you
want to increase from the list
hmm um
holocron this game definitely did have
marketing but i will say that it feels
like a lot of the thq
nordic games have lesser marketing so
like i said i did play this game
several years ago um out of pax and it
did have a booth at a pax but yeah
um like i don't feel like the most
recent dark side has had as much
marketing
i just think thq nordic doesn't have as
much of a budget that's my impression
uh reviewer you watch got 120 hours out
of this game but then gave it a 6.5 out
of 10 why would you play a game for 120
hours if you didn't like it
um well because that's their job as a
reviewer
so you kind of have to to make sure that
you
get an understanding of it only 20
people in the team i'm not sure but i do
imagine it was a pretty small team so
yeah i think that maybe people will
uh have an easier or a better
understanding of the thq nordic games if
they look at them as double a and not
aaa which maybe they've accidentally
hurt themselves with the image there
because people associate thq with aaa
but they are technically an entirely
separate studio
um okay i don't know which of these i
care about yet
i would like to have more key i think
so
[Music]
we could do that i think i don't know
yet
special attacks and perks okay let's do
close combat
select the weapon type unarmed
oh this could be pretty extensive by the
looks of things
i have all these that's what it's
telling me or is it yeah
that looks pretty cool xxy let's do it
you can now perform your special attack
when you have the correct weapon type
equipped
so it has to be unarmed and yeah i can't
afford anything else
i'm just gonna have a look through this
menu uh once you have more upgrade
points remember to spend them on perks
correct yes
oh that's what i was just doing perks cy
freak
is telling me i need bones
i'm sure it says behind my webcam and i
can't see it something points
gear it has a star next to it
okay
these are just health regen okay it's an
interesting system
i don't feel like i'm in tremendous need
of it just yet um
let me take everything you have good sir
and you thank you
okay let's keep going
let's do it
look an emergency box from the once was
a rare sight there once was
i'm interested in the law
and like i said the only thing i really
had seen people say were
complaints that there was too much
exposition but so far i'm i'm fine with
the exposition that's in here
now i hope i meet the person that i'm
talking to it looks weak
the claw bar should come in handy okay
cool
let's do it
ah i see
whoa whoa
it's time to find a way out of this
place no really i mean it
okay sounds good let's do it
no okay
a rabbit sleep you say cute
okay we good
[Music]
the morks produce biomatter in their
multi-organ that they shed
under distress bombs
including i tried to do it i just tried
yeah okay
excuse me i'm very much up in your [ __ ]
i cannot see
just give me a second everybody just let
me back up
pretty cool
i keep wanting people to attack me for
this parry system
to pay off but uh
it's pretty easy yeah it's not it's not
a thing that it's gonna take me a while
to learn
how are you still alive no you don't
there we go okay cool bioblobs you
absorbed a bioblob these
points used to unlock mutations you can
like bioblocks by defeating molks
okay cool
does seem like a thing i should explore
eventually
for now we will keep moving i will say
the traversal is nice like i like the
the running and jumping feel cool so
should i fall in order but with guns and
starring rocket raccoon not
quite not that far off though
actually in terms of level design but
not quite
um okay i wonder how long it took them
to make this game it feels like it was
probably
five years or so but i could be way off
who knows
okay it is very uh
a very nice mix of naturalist and sci-fi
like this stuff what is this the last of
us
toxinol built vessels called arcs
to save themselves from the impending
doom
but was it too late it is only
from the flight logs of the single arc
they left behind
that we know other arcs traveled through
the sky
and beyond it seems those that came
before
us never lost hope in finding a new
home so radiation killed everybody
what it seems like seems like radiation
is a problem
oh okay
interesting
okay i wasn't expecting something like
this
i wish the f of v was wider
i don't love a super wide fov but i
think that's just a personal preference
thing right
uh do i like it so far there are
certainly things that i like and things
that i don't like so much
um not sure yet i haven't haven't played
a ton yet or played maybe half an hour
if even so
um okay so what am i trying to do
exactly
to line these up i suppose
okay great cool
i overthought that
there are few records of the chain of
events that led to the big apocalypse
eons ago
but it's clear the world wasn't prepared
for how
recklessly the toxin or corporation
would make its mark on the world
their rare earth mining and nuclear
industries
generated tons of waste and without
consideration they dumped it all in
landfills until they ran out of space
that's when they made the big mistake
they began dumping the toxic waste in
the surf just off the coast instead
assuming that it would sink and decay
the corporations
they were right how's the weather down
there
a great question wonderful dottie costa
in a hotel room where it's really warm
feels like it's summer outside
apparently i don't know haven't been
outside it's eight days in their
offspring
and what had an inconceivable impact on
biodiversity in the entire ecosystem
the world as they knew it crumbled as
nature
retaliated it would never be the same
again
and what remained of it became ours
cool it's a pretty simple plot that's
all right
um you know i understand
big bad corporation do bad carbon
emissions
etc
sound of spark metal going pew pew is
never
a good thing is that what that was it's
coming from behind that door thank you
sir
a warning label the box looks like a
potential
brain melt
it is very um heavily narrated puzzling
to short-circuit the door
that makes it feel a little bit like a
kids game
uh are you sure that i haven't done this
because i feel like i have
the colors match each other so that just
means this one has to be flipped the
other way around
move left make them count
it says match they all match perfectly
did you want me to turn that one off or
something
quite a shock to the system
didn't think that that would be what you
wanted let's try it
[Music]
wasn't that what it was
there you go what did i not have it
at that huh
did i just need to move it away and then
move it back
did i miss something just now
i don't know maybe i i don't i don't
know how i missed something but maybe i
did
i don't know
okay
perfectly countering an enemy will stun
them ah cool great that's what i was
hoping
he's outnumbered you'd better help him
out
who's this cool guy
boom [ __ ]
the unspeakable hand is cool i look
forward to getting more of that stuff it
is neat
trying to do whatever this this stun
thing it says
is that supposed to be it
doesn't really matter i'm just killing
everyone it's not difficult use more key
because i do like the key
okay yeah it just now goes bang when you
carry block all right mate
get away from my friend
that's the last of them let's talk to
the wheeled one before i certainly hope
it gets harder there are systems that
i'm just not using which
uh you certainly could use um because
it's not a ton of challenge it's like in
resident evil 8 i'm not guarding at all
ever because i just never need to
uh which is probably on me but
luke lu luke toffee okay
um did anyone else have anything on him
oh
he runs look at that oh it's a little
cutie
oh my god it's so easy to make me aw at
something
he wants to thank you for taking his
side against the scavengers
he sounds familiar you just can't
figure out why
he presents himself as out of date he
knows he's way overdue
but he hasn't given up it's existential
my dude
i'm surprised that you don't recognize
him you were just a child back then
the night everything changed
the legend of the one-eyed child that
grew up as an
outcast is old
but the evil it had fled had left a mark
a facial scar to remember the past
the question is what
there's no doubt you're the child and
that what looper lupin
did to your village your mumma and popsy
was
he says it has taken you a long time to
bring the past back
up to the present to find your way back
but he's grateful
it was after the attack that the unity
fell apart
your mum's disciples divided and
asking the formed questions
the impending threat of the world eaters
bringing down the tree of life is
ever so close he also worries about the
jagne tribe
that's actively working for a doomsday
boy
always somebody looking for a doomsday
you know
[Music]
had it not been for the tree of life no
one would have survived
he hopes you at least remember dude i
have no idea what you're talking about i
have no [ __ ] clue what you're talking
about
what tree by default dialings are set to
advance from one npc line to the next
automatically oh yes i know thank you
back in the long ago oh my oh
my oh my gosh
i really like the style
you're the coolest man i've ever seen in
my life as it's a bit of a hike here
from the village
he wonders if your mumma knows you are
here mumma
[Music]
you're such a good child so you probably
did
even the young forget
[Music]
he understands why you came all the way
out here
to see them the potato people
is that what i did potato people or nano
are a wonder somehow interlinked with
this little tree here
fueling its source of life okay
cool you might be right
like potatoes they're packed with energy
an excellent source of key
[Music]
oh my god i love him so much
this man is the love of my life glitter
grass he says you should get over there
and ruffle it
see if you can make one come out of
hiding
okay cool
so is this in the time before the world
winter [ __ ] because of the eagle evil
megacorp
i suspect so
look at his little ears moving my god
animals what do we do to deserve them
this is pretty i feel like it needs a
little bit more contrast but um
also worth noting that uh i am in a
hotel room on hotel room wi-fi we have
lost a few frames and youtube
compression makes the gameplay look a
lot worse
than it actually is if you watch the
video uh after it's live it should look
even
um like when i stop streaming it should
process and look better than it does
right now because i feel like the stream
is not an accurate representation of
what i'm seeing just to be clear it does
look a lot sharper than the stream so
i don't know that i'd time that guy out
for 300 seconds scott i think i would
just ban him
thank you um okay
you just want me to ruffle it how did
you get here sir you're fine
god the love of my life time travel come
out for everyone
[Music]
the nano's key energy is just what the
pennsy
needs to complete its cycle and grow
into a tree of life
uh okay what is pensa
it's moving fast out here
but what you show me your pencil frame
what's your pencil look like you saw up
there where you met
will eventually grow into a tree of life
and start giving back to nature
it'll be the heart of the land correct
totti the correct way to a woman's heart
is
uh just speed like the tree for a long
time
as they become one with the tree
[Music]
it had to be fun to voice actually and
he wants you to use his
but asks you to be gentle the nano are
sensitive beings
an embodiment of key the primal energy
okay are you gonna give me
[Music]
cool
okay
this troll isn't gonna be that easy
didn't he say to be gentle and i feel
like i just smacked that thing about
i didn't i probably could have picked it
up grateful for all the help we didn't
even need a net
lots of nano out there that need to be
guided to the roots of the pensa
tree where can i find them i assume it
needs endless
[Music]
[Music]
one day he hopes the tree will have
grown tall enough to sustain the world
i'm into it again very naturally today
your focus is getting this one to become
one
with the tree some avatar [ __ ] are we
gonna like what do they call it when
they connect
their bits with the trees bits
and i really like the music too i wonder
who composed this this this particular
song is really lovely
so so far i think the combat is
but has some interesting potential i
didn't find the parry system to be very
satisfying
i like the world i like the characters
um i like the style
i do feel like there is a little bit
uh it explains itself a little bit too
much which does make it oddly feel like
a kid's game i don't know if that's
their intent though like it could be
that it's for a broad audience
yeah i think there's potential for it to
get more interesting as it goes on
[Music]
this guy alone though my gosh
the level design is also sort of
uninteresting but again
very early
from this day on he'll make nurturing
the pencil
into a tree of life a life goal
not only for our village thank you chris
i really appreciate that i'm very
excited
everybody is the combat holding my hands
no because it's not hard enough
um for anyone who doesn't know i have
tendonitis feels peaceful
in both of my wrists so any button
mashing game can be really difficult for
me to play and quite painful for me to
play
uh so far there's not enough button
mashing in this you can already see the
effects from how
those before us acted and unless
something changes we're doomed
the land won't survive the side effects
of the old world's industrial advances
[Music]
how did elvis so wise how does he know
village before
your mumma comes looking for you you did
good here today
i love the idea of being like my mom
only cares about wong fu
she never cared about me
cares about two things wang and foo no
she's got lots on her mind and needs
rest after the raid last night
wonders a wow player family live or not
in the destiny is she all right
i think this game is very cute we go
from cute elvis to
cute but no shirt boy
it's part of a trail you can follow
you like that if we can jump between
time zones i think is cool too he says
he remembers
every single day he devoted to growing
the tree of life
now he's afraid is it the same man in
vain
i made it too dramatic that that i could
never get away with that uh
we had questions here
um i forgot what i was saying okay uh
the tree started to die in the end of
days begun and it wasn't long after that
i believe that
let's go world eaters i think i
understand the end of days there's a
concept
the genetic evolution that occurred
after the apocalypse
the toxinol corporation inflicted on the
land set the world eater's dna into
overdrive
his friend gizmo is working on a mech
town and needs help defeating the jumbo
puff at the end of the west room every
family member has tried to call me
during the stream i've had the refocus
still repairing his october
everybody trying to call me the merc
puff that dwells deep
down under the surface at the end of the
northwest route
very cute names noco has tamed the majut
and is preparing to take on the hoof
puff at the end of the east route
finally goop is almost done with the goo
glide
machine able to ride the waves of the
surf all the way out to the porchy puff
at the end of the route to the south
east it's endearing for sure
and i will say
his friends are gearing up to stop the
world eaters
there's one at the end of each uh this
stuff took someone a very long time
the road ahead won't be easy but he's
counting on your support
his friend okay okay well we may be said
to
be leaving the tutorial i want you to
understand that you'll
all die if the tree i do feel like
you've given me that context
yes oh my god everybody
his friends have prepared something
specific for each world eater
the mekton the octopod the majoot and
the goo glide are
almost ready to ride
regardless you'll meet again once you've
played your part in the tribe war
and the situation with the world i got
you fam
i will i will do whatever i can thank
you i love net
yeah rarity zero oh okay i see
this dramatic sound design okay please
stay safe in here you're very important
to me
my god look at you the cutest thing i've
ever seen what's all this
mutated fruits potentially there they
are i think
they even what's this is that a sex toy
is that a is that your vibrator that
you've got up there king
that's cool yeah it's lonely out here i
bet you sleeping right there
okay you're getting the hang of it
opening doors don't mind if i do thank
you for the comments
quickest way out is through the roof
where they came in and the rope looks
strong enough to climb
okay let's do it
i'm excited to see the world
time to go pro in the lacrosse league
this is very pretty i feel like i'm
getting repetitive
uh but it happens when you feel like you
have to speak a lot on streams
i know without help it can't
i am aware of that thank you you've told
me a number of times
thank you though look we begin the video
game
beautiful
breath of the wild zelda vibe i could
see there being
a breath of the wild vibe
in um how pastel it is
like no i don't think this game is going
to be at all like legend of zelda breath
of the wild
but i do feel like the the pastel
coloring in the
open areas feels um
a little bit so inclined did you think
that i hadn't learned how to sprint
son because it did take me a while
a signpost maps it out for the
cartographically
challenged i do think it is giving me a
little bit too much
information but again
let's see
did what he just do what i thought he
did did he just pee on that side
hang on let me watch the stream back
there's like a minute delay so
where is it come on dizzy did he pee on
it
he for sure peed on it yeah wow i didn't
expect that um okay fast travel to
signposts
cool i love a fast travel where shall we
go
i don't know i feel like maybe we go
here first but i'm just gonna head
just forward for now
i guess this part will give you an
indication of oh my
what is this shock raccoon man doing
blizzard
hybrid that must be the world eater that
chewed off out of dates later i love him
you'll need a hat trick to bring that
down
nice the perfect eaters have made their
marks on our world
over time come on man
yeah they did the thing
oh uh okay it was drugs
behind the waterfall it was drugs cool
that's not the first nor the last
village it'll leave in its wake
does anyone live out here this looks
like halo
this is the bridges here look like halo
3.
um all right let's roll let's let's
investigate see what happened with the
cool shark man a survivor glad to see
someone made it out
that answered that question loving the
character design
loving it huge fan the artists did an
amazing thing
a little bit star wars he's heard the
stories about the terror inflicted by
the world eaters to other enclaves
but never expected one to come all the
way here
your imbalance is two hobbs that
completes a wholeness that flows through
all things
at times you'll be able to manifest your
balance through deeds and oh okay neat
few of those who always act in the same
manner and now wholeness is the sum of
the choices we make and the actions we
take the balance of your actions creates
your aura score which affects the
dialogue with other characters
okay he doesn't know what your
connection is to this place
but something tells him you've stayed
true to your heart
thank you i absolutely have okay
interacting with captives and psi
shrines will award you with psi points
that you can use to unlock
psionic powers uh power is going to be
unlocked once you haven't reached the
required dark or light in a balance okay
interested to see how that plays out do
we get light or dark points from
dialogue
anyway he needs help and says it's by
your multiple things potentially
not by your intentions let me help
that's a spark of enlighten you thank
you
what's there to like about light it
hurts to look at
not as much as always making this
personal and you're always trying to
pretend it's not
i think that the dark one is cuter
okay fine
very dramatic all right i would love to
let's do that all right
oh damn that's this action movie
there's out of date again he must have
missed something important
oh hello my love i will be there for you
just give me oh
i'm just gonna run to him out of date
says you will make a better stand
against the world eaters with the
support
of a tribe and there are two nearby
wherefore i wonder why they chose to
write that that way yeah to have him
leave
where you leave him and then have him
show up easy as the cause that was the
decision somebody made worse than ever
teetering on the brink of war oh no
the myriad's conviction to stop the
world eaters began when the leviathans
rose from the depths of the surf
siding with the myriad's movement i do
feel like the individual
fragmented sentence is a very well
written logical thing to do
it's very is it the right thing poetic
one thing's certain though
destiny arrives all the same
he laughed at your comment chris g bacon
i've only ever had one conviction
to bring balance to the world by wiping
out the weak
they believe a cleansing is necessary to
restore the world
and want to let the world eaters bring
down the tree of life
but siding with chutney isn't
necessarily a bad thing
um
okay out of date says someone needs to
break the stalemate and shift the
balance of power to either japanese
or myriad side okay i think i'll go with
the ones who aren't trying to cleanse
the weak
thank you leaves the tribe's seafoods
myriad especially
will listen to you and expect you to pay
at least
one of them a visit and play your part
myriad is convinced that defeating the
world eaters is the only way the world
can be saved
but they've been forced to focus on
their rivalry with the japanese tribe
regardless you'll meet again once you've
played your part in the tribe war and
the situation with the world eaters
okay
yikes bro that's a yikes from me dog uh
i support the week as someone who
literally like i said has to stop
streaming after an hour because i had a
really bad aspect attack this morning
which means that i have to catch up on
work
let's not cleanse the week that's a huge
yikes for me
god damn wild
okay so um i'm not gonna go
with the jagne
wait this is this is the myriad right
yeah
they would maybe murder me so we'll pass
on that another fork in the road
it's either the tunnel or the motor
bridge what would it be
um
i wish it hadn't said that so i could
just organically make the decision
no no no but that's because that's
that's the jag me and this is okay so we
are going this way
um hang on didn't i have uh
no no that's the wrong menu oh no i
screwed that up
so i had a mutation or something
yeah side powers
i would love to get more things please
to press down the input you have oh
that's pretty cool i don't feel like i
need that yet but i might if the game
gets harder so for now we're gonna do
that
yes cool i love this kind of combat um
if it gets yeah beautiful
okay put that on b and then we go what
is it
uh
that's neat oh did i just drown
oh my god okay okay that's
all right uh i would i thought it was a
shallow stream
and then i was just firing through there
and
i'm dead my god
okay not it though i good to know
[Laughter]
it's unusual that natural tunnels like
this still exist
most of them got flooded i think by what
um all right
i'm gonna make it to the tribe who would
not kill the asthmatics
oh hey are you should i get involved or
should i just sort of
nobody mind me keep yourselves have fun
not my problem this looks really pretty
i want to assure you all that i'm sure
youtube is making it look like butt
it looks quite nice this area was
beautiful before the tribe war began
look at it now oh you've got also actual
trenches out here
okay my brain really wants me to explore
every
part of this because there's probably
treasure
it's another health patch that's cool we
like health patches
as a mage i am a fan of health patches
at least that's what i'm trying to be
i i just want to confirm that i am okay
going to the right tribe
because yeah big ol yikes on the other
side there though i think that
narratively it's telling me that i have
to
get the two to work together that's the
myriad tribe's fortress
cool baby friends or foe you should head
up there
that way you'll know he rhymed
very nice okay let me just piss on this
real quick
see now i would understand if maybe they
let's see didn't want to be my best
mates
i'm being honest i'm just out here
peeing on my flag the minute i arrive
you can't just claim other people's
flags dude that door
if you go there you'd better make an
entrance hello
says they're wary of strangers they're
at war
i could have could i say this more
politely maybe
doesn't know if the sifu will have time
for you but
he'll let you in to find out
appreciate that thank you um your
security is terrible
and i was rude that's my biggest
takeaways from everything that happened
here he does need to drink more water
jason though i suspected that his uh
urine was bright yellow because of the
radiation or whatever
the myriad tribe act on understanding of
the greater good and a code of honor
they believe uniting the tribes is the
only way to restore the peace
the sifu is convinced that defeating the
world eaters and saving the tree of life
is the only way to make the world a
better place i agree
even if i think that that man is very
cool welcomes you to the myriad
and introduces
but he was hoping you'd show up the news
of a vigilante ronin on crusade
crossing the great wall through the
cracking bunker 101 has preceded you
i've murdered everybody i've seen
how did anybody spread that everybody
i've met
except for the old one out of date
is dead
hmm
the wall that separates them from the
other side the wasteland you came from
he guesses the time spent there just
left a blank
space in your memory as empty and barren
as the wasteland itself correct he's
convinced you've returned for a reason
and is glad you chose to come here i'm
real sorry i peed on your side dude but
thank you
something about your spirit that sparks
memories of you as a
kiddling he can still sense you're
kind-hearted
the sifu says sometimes one memory can
make another come to life
he hasn't thought about your mumma for
ages even though she taught him a lot
yeah he was one of the original
disciples
cool that explains why she only cares
about one foot of unarmed combat and the
six weapons
the boomerang the shuriken the bow the
staff
the nanchok and the hook and chain okay
if those are weapons i can get we're
gonna have a fun time
time to set the past aside at least for
now
unrest is sweeping the land and there
are rivals in
all directions a huge bummer that even
when the world is dying
between the tribes they're still just
tribes fighting his understanding of the
greater good
and establishing a code of honor if you
believe there's some good in everyone
there's still
hope for tomorrow you'll unite the
tribes and defeat the world eaters to
save the tree of life
i definitely agree eot 21
that the narrator is a very good speaker
it'd uh
hurt the game significantly if his voice
weren't so pleasant
um i do believe that's good in everyone
and there is still hope for tomorrow
correct i will absolutely join the
myriad because you guys don't want me to
die
no trying to cleanse the week you
understand that there's no harm in doing
good to others
all the goods are gonna have sn the sifu
was waiting for something to tip the
balance in their favor
and with you by their side he's
confident you can unite the other tribes
the myriad were placed here to fulfill a
certain purpose
chosen to unite the tribes and take
control of their destiny
the tribe okay
i feel good about it i feel like i made
a good choice here today
their kin have run out of options and
found themselves backed into a corner
even those who desire peace have been
forced to prepare for war
i wish there were another way it's true
you need to take the struggle
to the enemy or the enemy will bring it
to you okay
he wants you to focus these are the new
rival
outposts your tribe needs to take
control of
interesting i wasn't expecting
uh gta san andreas turf war situation
out here
but i will take it he says you'll regret
not being on their side
the only way you'll learn their secrets
and the tribe weapon now is if you
defeat him
and that will never happen i mean he
looks cool as [ __ ] both have gentle
minds
but he says they want to wage a gentle
war
a war that bonds as much as it breaks
once you've dealt with the rivals
outposts
you'll challenge their sifu to unite
their tribe
they passed the point of no return as
their word
seeing you brings back his memories
myriad wants you to agree code of honor
unity
agreement oh i didn't even mean to skip
that one i don't know what he said the
memories you make with your family are
strong
and can sometimes come to life passing
the old village on your way to the first
rival old village
cool i'm interested in these like
flashback things that they're suggesting
too
um but i feel like this is the point
where i should end the stream which is
kind of a bummer because i feel like i
just started the game
uh this really does feel like it is just
beginning to open up
um and maybe i will hang out here a
little bit more but
yeah like i said i unfortunately had an
asthma attack this morning which just
set me back time-wise pretty
significantly so
i gotta deal with that but uh i will
potentially stream again a little bit
later on which we're still raising money
for doctors without borders
trying to raise ten thousand dollars i
think we're just over eight thousand
right now um
i'm not sure when is the only problem
when i finish work
so thank you all for watching this is
obviously the first hour of the game
certainly a lot of dialogue yeah um that
i think if it continues
at this frequency i would end up
skipping a lot more of but right now i'm
i'm okay with learning the law uh
obviously map is unlocking
i do hope the the combat gets a little
bit more complex or more challenging
um i'm interested but don't imagine that
i will end up
adoring this game but i could be wrong
who knows so yeah if you guys want to
catch more of this game i will stream it
on twitch either later today or tomorrow
um i will see you all there thank you
for watching the first hour of biomutant
i do also have to thank thq for giving
me the code for the game uh which is how
i was able to play it
uh a day early so